[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a neo-noir martial arts
film called ninja assassin
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the movie begins in a tattoo shop owned
by an old experienced man he is working
on a young gangster when a minion brings
an envelope filled with black sand the
gangsters do not know what it means but
the old man freezes in shock he reveals
that the black sand denotes the arrival
of the brutal deadliest ninjas in the
world he encountered them long ago and
has first-hand experience to know how
dangerous they are when the gangsters
call him a coward he shows them a nasty
scar on his chest that was caused by a
ninja attack he was born with a heart on
the right side of his chest which is the
only reason he is still alive to this
day suddenly a man's head is sliced in
half splattering blood everywhere then a
wire drops from the ceiling and pulls a
man upwards when he is thrown back only
pieces of his gut reach the ground the
ninjas stay hidden in the shadows and
slice people's bodies and limbs in one
go creating a bloodbath only after
everyone is dead do we see the ninjas
coming out of the dark corners of the
room then we are introduced to the ozunu
clan of japan it is a clan of ninjas led
by the ruthless lord ozunu the clan
collects children from around the world
and makes them go through a series of
brutal training techniques to become the
ultimate ninja assassins they're popular
among the world leaders but hidden from
the rest of the world anyone who
provides the clan with a hundred pounds
of gold can hire their assassins and
ensure the death of the person they want
to target the ozunu clan has been
working from the shadows for more than a
hundred years and is behind the deaths
of the russian president the japanese
prime minister jeffrey epstein and many
other higher figures anyone who knows
about them is scared to ever come across
them in one of the sessions lord ozunu
introduces a new kid named ryzo to the
rest of the group he was abandoned by
his parents and is taken into the clan
by the leader something tells ozunu that
rhizo will be the leader of the clan
after him because of the expectation the
training is tougher for rhizo by the
time he is 10 he has scars all over his
body from the punishment he gets for
making mistakes one of the important
qualities a ninja should have is his
ability to stay hidden rhizo is made to
walk down a squeaky wooden floor but a
single sound it makes results in his
feet being cut by a kyoketsu shogue at
night the kid can hardly sleep because
of the pain then he witnesses kindness
for the first time in his life when a
girl puts ointment on his wounds her
name is kirikou and she is a fellow
ninja in training the kids are taught to
not have any kind of emotions but
kirikou is different she doesn't believe
in the violence and killings that the
clan supports time passes quickly and
both rhizo and kirikou grow up together
hardly talking but always looking out
for each other rhizo has now become the
most talented ninja azunu has ever
trained however in a match with his
senior takeshi he loses because of a
foul tactic of the opponent the master
allows it and instead blames rhizo for
being weak he uses an extremely painful
finger pushing technique on rhizo that
causes the guy to crumple in pain his
ultimate test is to survive the night
without medical assistance upon
returning the next morning ozunu sees
him ready for the new day's training and
is proud of the student for passing the
test soon rhizo becomes the most
talented ninja of the clan beating the
opponent blindfolded and with his hands
bound kirikou is proud of him but on the
other hand becomes disenchanted with
ozunu's way of life she frequently
disregards the little rules of the clan
and is warned by rhizo he is scared that
if the leader finds out he will take her
heart away but kirikou says her heart is
with rhizo so it can never be stolen in
a training session she is asked to hurt
an opponent with a knife when kirikou is
unable to do it posunu cuts her face and
throws her into a cage rizzo sneaks out
to meet with her and feed her water a
few days later on a rainy night kirikou
climbs a wall to escape and encourages
rhizo to join her but he chooses to stay
wanting to remain loyal to the clan
since it is all he has ever known
eventually kirikou is captured and is
set to be executed senior takeshi
impales her through the heart in front
of everyone a part of rhizo dies that
day but he still decides to stay loyal
to the clan the scene cuts to a few
years later in berlin europol
headquarters a forensic teacher named
micah has found evidence about the
existence of the clan unaware of how
dangerous this piece of information can
be she brings it to her senior at work
maslow he refuses to believe that there
is a secret ninja organization that only
elites know about but micah shows him
the reports which prove the connection
between the flow of money from world
leaders and the deaths of many known
figures maslow now interested decides to
dig further into the matter eventually
they find out that a high-ranking kgb
agent sabaten has made similar reports
in the past but as his work started to
gain recognition he was kicked out of
his post for being delusional and
eventually was killed then we see that
rhizo is also in the city of berlin
living in a shabby apartment for a
special task he trains every morning
over a block of nails like he was taught
by his master one day he goes to the
local laundry shop and comes across a
woman she seems to be friendly but he
instantly recognizes her as a ninja the
two attack each other and indulge in a
tough fight a while later we see blood
dripping out of a washing machine and
the girl's body spinning inside of it
meanwhile micah takes her investigation
a step forward and goes to meet the wife
of the former agent who was killed for
talking about the clans the woman
reveals her husband was a strong
courageous man but after the scandal
everything changed he became so much of
a coward that every door and window had
a minimum of two locks and every corner
of the house was well lit he left no
space for the shadows so the ninjas had
no place to hide still one night the
lights went off and he was killed the
next day at work a higher official comes
to micah's office for evaluation it is
clear that he is there to keep an eye on
her because people are talking about her
being too curious about things that
don't concern her that evening micah
returns home cautiously but finds out
there has been a power outage in the
entire block still she goes inside her
dark apartment but is then attacked by a
ninja surprisingly enough another ninja
saves her life and kills the assassins
he is none other than rhizo another
flashback shows us the adult rhizo on
his mission to complete his first
assassination he lets all of his
frustration out and brutally kills the
target after the mission he comes to the
rooftop to meet the rest of the clan
lord ozunu says that he is proud of
rhizo and calls him closer to his
surprise rhizo attacks him with the
kyoketsu shogue that cuts him across the
face and an eye his fellow ninja attacks
him and pushes him off the building
after hurting him gravely rhizo barely
survives the fall by landing in the
water then ever since he recovered he
has been working against the clan
intervening in all of ozune's
assassination attempts he saved micah's
life for the same reason they drive to a
hotel and change their clothes because
ninjas use a special smelling technique
to track them following that she gives
maslow a call and tells him she is with
rhizo the man has been asked to capture
rhizo as soon as he comes into view he
knows that rhizo is not their primary
opponent but he has to obey the orders
for his own life hence when the three
meet to discuss the next step in the
plan rhizo is surrounded by police and
arrested he is taken to a hideout and
chained in a solitary prison micah finds
out that maslow arrested him out of
desperation still he refuses to let go
of rhizo because he will be the safest
in the prison at night micah goes to him
and offers him water rhizo takes the
opportunity to reveal that the assassins
will be here any second micah tries to
warn maslow but it is too late the
lights go off and the ninjas come out of
the shadows even with the most advanced
weapon the soldiers are proven to be
weak against the warriors micah unlocks
the chains off rhizo's hands right
before he is killed he fights the ninjas
and asks micah to run away since he
cannot save both of them rhizo is the
best student the ozunu clan has ever had
but still going against a whole horde of
ninjas is difficult for him in the end
he and takeshi end up on the road
takeshi picks up his sword to end
rhizo's life for good but micah arrives
at the right time and hits him with her
car she brings rhizo to a hotel although
he is severely injured he refuses to go
to the doctor she sits beside him
talking to his unconscious self she
apologizes for not being of use to him
and thanks him for her life after that
she pulls a tracking device that tells
maslow their location but before the
police can come the assassins appear out
of nowhere and abduct rhizo when the
police arrive they only find micah
sitting on the sofa she tells them that
rhizo was abducted ten minutes ago back
in the clan's base rhizo is presented to
lord ozunu the man gives him one last
chance to apologize but rhizo refuses
ozunu is especially furious because once
he had believed that rhizo was going to
replace him and take his place as the
master of the clan he makes rhizo stand
in the same position kirikou was
executed rhizo is then hit with the
finger jabbing technique thrice while
most people would die from a single blow
of the technique rhizo just vomits blood
alongside it he also vomits a tracking
device before the ninjas see it micah
with an entire police force enters the
premises and wreaks havoc many ninjas
are killed with explosives so hiding in
the dark doesn't work in an ensuing
battle many people from both parties are
killed rhizo is confronted by takeshi
and his people even though the fight
isn't fair he kills all the ninjas and
waits for takeshi's attack then the two
fight with all their might and rhizo
wins in the end takeshi's limbs and
eventually neck are cut off now the only
person rizzo has to face is his former
master ozunu he finds the old man inside
a room sitting calmly while people die
outside the master proves his expertise
by disappearing into thin air and coming
out of the shadows behind rhizo with
only a push he sends rhizo flying to the
other room then they both bring out
their swords and engage in a fierce
sword fight ozunu gives him yet another
chance to apologize claiming himself to
be rhizo's father but rhizo replies that
he is no one's son and the second he
kills ozunu will be his first breath in
life with that being said the two leap
at each other but ozunu disappears yet
again suddenly micah comes into the room
hoping to help rhizo however ozunu
reappears from the shadows and attacks
her with a sword right through her chest
the fight falls into a zunu's side until
rhizo plays the same trick and slices
his body repeatedly from the shadows in
the end he is killed with a sword to his
shoulder rhizo brings micah outside and
the paramedics come to her aid it turns
out she was also born with a heart on
the right side of her chest which means
she will survive in the last scene rhizo
jumps off the wall of the academy as
kirikou wanted him to
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching